china vive dos realidades sobre el Coby
19 por un lado la asegura que pregonan
las autoridades y por el otro los
hospitales al borde del colapso la
situación sanitaria está en un momento
delicado donde los centros de atención
funcionan al tope de sus capacidades
es mucho mejor ahora Estamos operando a
plena capacidad el 90% del personal
médico aquí se infectó y se recuperó
ahora el 90% del personal ha vuelto al
trabajo
La ola de contagios que padece el
cliente asiático puede alcanzar el
millón de muertes durante el invierno
según la epidemiólogos y el momento
inquieta a los ciudadanos sobre todo a
las personas mayores
siento que deberían haber tomado una
serie de acciones antes de abrir como
aconsejar que precauciones deben tomar
las personas de cierta edad que deben
hacer los jóvenes y permitir que la
gente prepare Algún medicamento o lo
distribuyan
para el gobierno chino la situación está
bajo control y exige a la comunidad
internacional que sean razonables con
sus medidas la situación de prevención y
control de epidemias de China es
predecible y controlable recientemente
muchos estados miembros de la Unión
Europea han indicado que dan una
calurosa bienvenida a Los visitantes de
China y que no tomaran ninguna medida
restrictiva el centro europeo para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
y otros organismos profesionales también
han dejado claro con anterioridad que no
es razonable imponer medidas
restrictivas a Los viajeros de China la
Unión Europea debería Escuchar más estas
voces racionales y tener una visión
objetiva y justa de la situación de
prevención y control de la epidemia en
China
desde el domingo el gobierno abrirá
terminales para recibir vuelos
internacionales la apertura durante la
compleja situación sanitaria sucede en
un momento donde a razón del año nuevo
chino se espera el aumento de los viajes
de pasajeros que según las autoridades
podrían aumentar en un 99,5% con
respecto a las cifras del mismo periodo
del año anterior